today we're talking to a guy who created
a meme coin
as a joke and became a paper billionaire
in 30 minutes right now what are you
worth by the way this is g
everybody welcome to the show what's up
coffees or fam
what's up man how's it going to be a
paper billionaire what are you worth
right now
all right no i'm 3.5 billion
okay okay we're not in a bubble guys
we're not a bubble
hey that's the top beautiful so
let's explain to everyone what happened
what happened i've been trying to warn
people and by this by the time this
comes out
my video on safe moon will come out it's
about meme coins
how they're ridiculous speculative it
you know we're in a bubble
whatever don't waste your money it's
gambling now what people have done
though to prove this out better than i
ever could
is one guy went and he created what's a
scam coin
it literally the acronym was scam and it
was worth 70 million dollars
overnight i made this token simple cool
automatic money or scam
so what the [ __ ] coin only been out of
our
70 million dollar market cap bro
i saw this thought it was hilarious
whatever you saw this
and said i i can do better than that
that's stress something million i can do
like 10 billion
okay so you create your own
coin and what is the coin called pump
coin like pump bomb that charge
like pumping down stomp coin now we
should say from the get go
do not invest in this coin yeah you can
lose your money
yeah you you as a joke you sent me
69 million yeah 420 yeah
yeah 69 million four hundred and twenty
thousand four hundred and four hundred
and twenty let me show these people
let me show these people you guys see
that oh y'all can't see that
anyway it says 469 million points um
and these coins are essentially
worthless they were minted
last night yesterday yeah uh it's insane
it's stupid we're in a bubble but
you you tweeted about it right and you
and because you tweeted about it
like three times the coin
rocketed to billions of dollars in
valuation
i mean if i do like 1 billion then 3
billion and 5.5 billion
then drop to 30 billion so right now 3.2
billion right now
how much of that coin do you own like 99
percent
99 if you have one yeah i can just sell
it and dump the coin
how would you want to use a little money
yeah here's the thing
here's the thing with all these coins
guys the market caps are insane but
they're not real like that's the whole
thing you have to understand is
when you go and this is why i wanted to
bring you on is because the whole irony
is
you're worth billions of dollars on
paper you can't sell though
yeah how much of this could you
realistically get out
like 10 20 grand
but that's called my application no
point okay yeah it's it's stupid
so this is what i wanted to show you
guys is have an
actual coin creator talk to you guys
and explain how silly this whole thing
is you made it
what last night right literally last
year 20 minutes
i think it's hilarious that people are
doing it though because it does prove
out
the point which is that this is a stupid
bubble
these numbers aren't real like when it
says like it's a billion dollar market
cap
do you really think that the pump coin
is worth more than what what companies
are you currently worth more than
right now i mean maybe like nicola
okay well yeah so so i guess that's kind
of
true that's how you compete with them
right and you scam you can move the scam
so
yeah that's true that's true tell us
about the la county jail are you getting
practice for your scam
oh i mean yeah bro
my bad no it's okay this is a very well
organized interview this is
exactly what i was expecting what are
you gonna do with all this paper money
are you gonna go try to redeem it
somewhere
what i don't know it might be the other
coin you never know it's not gonna be
worth something guys don't listen to
this guy
this is complete crap it's junk it's
junk
i don't i don't even know what to do
with the 69 million you gave me
i'm just gonna i may just give this
wallet away one day
i may just give it to one lucky coffee
zilla fan make an nfc for the wallet
with nfc
take a picture make an nfc so stupid
listen to what you said
you go okay you have worthless tokens so
yeah make an
nft of your worthless tokens now it's
worth something
yeah people can pay for that
please guys please save your money i'm
so new to crypto and i'm just like
looking at all this stuff i'm like so
much of this is a gigantic scam man it's
so goofy
most of it yeah well thanks for coming
on
thanks for watching guys hope you are
entertained are we in a bubble
you let me know thanks for watching see
ya
[Music]
wake up and smell the coffee